we are learning more about who devin new
neces source was on the bogus Trump
wiretapping Intel that he claims to have
received recall that two weeks ago
Republican congressman Devin Nunez the
Trump a lie who's heading the house
Intel committees investigation into
Russian interference in the election
held a press conference saying Oh a
source told me that us intelligence
incidentally collected communications
from the Trump transition team that this
was part of their broader investigation
into Russia we now have found out that
according to for us officials the source
was the white house now semantics matter
here the White House might not be the
same as Trump the White House sometimes
is used interchangeably to mean sort of
the executive branch of government and
that's more than just the Oval Office
right but for officials are saying that
the information was given to nunus by
Ezra Cohen wat Nick the Senior Director
for Intel at the National Security
Council and Michael Ellis a lawyer at
the White House counsel's office and a
previously council was also counsel for
noon as his committee both are close to
the president but they are not the
president per se Cohen wat Nick worked
on the Trump transition team and was
brought to the White House by none other
than disgraced former national security
adviser Mike Flynn this furthers the
perception that the house Intel
committee led by Devin Nunez cannot
possibly pat carry out a fair full and
objective investigation everything we
learn is exposing the house
investigation is less and less credible
he's a puppet I mean that's pretty clear
he learned about this story from the
White House and then ran down
Pennsylvania Avenue a couple days later
to yell the White House about it on the
night of March 21st Nunez was riding in
an uber in DC got a phone call
immediately went to the White House the
next day he gave an impromptu press
conference to allow two to explain
announce what he had learned the night
before and it was oh yeah Trump actually
was wiretapped by us intelligence except
it was part of a larger investigation
into Russia again this is more an
indictment of trumps
tangle MIT with Russia because what he's
arguing is the US intelligence community
was surveilling some foreign power and
while listening in on that foreign
powers communications someone from the
Trump team pops on to the line or on
email or whatever it was that the means
of communication was newness is going
around touting this Pat like this is a
vindication for Trump but it's actually
an indictment of Trump if it's true we
don't even know whether it's true at
this point yeah very interesting I mean
it just it just seems like Devin noon is
his loyalty is more so to the President
and to his own political party than it
is to his own constituents in California
to the American people who want to see a
credible investigation and study
committee that he completely bypassed
with this information no doubt about it
and Adam Schiff who's the ranking member
he's the top Democrat on that same house
intelligence committee he has recently
come out with a statement where he says
it raises a profound question why they
were not directly provided to the White
House by the national security staff and
instead were provided through a
circuitous route involving the Chairman
if that was designed to hide the origin
of the materials that just raises
profound questions about just what the
White House is doing that need to be
answered so let's think this through
what should we take away from this
revelation that Devin Nunez needs to go
because he clearly can't be a fair
arbiter in this investigation that if
Trump was surveilled incidentally in
this way it's because his team was in
touch with foreign powers but what have
trumpets taken from this that Obama
wiretapped me that trumps Obama
wiretapped me claims were right which is
not even what is being claimed nevermind
what is being implied here and Nunez
still is saying that he's not going to
reveal his sources but he is
characterizing them as whistleblowers
trying to reveal wrongdoing that also
would not be true I mean every aspect of
this is being misinterpreted by the
trumpets if it is true that US
intelligence was surveilling foreign
powers and that trump team members were
incidentally surveilled during that
foreign surveillance
there's nothing illegal about that and
by definition these would not be
whistleblowers I mean there's nothing
we've heard from Nunez or trumpets about
these revelations that is actually based
in reality right and he even admits
himself that this would not be illegal
it would just be perhaps unpalatable to
the American public right it's
interesting when the media goes up to
him asking to reveal what his sources
yeah and he says we're not going to talk
about any of that as if to say there's a
story here keep looking into this you're
also going to think this is a joke but
this is for real Sean Spicer in reactant
reaction to this said quote the
obsession with who talk to whom and when
is not the answer it should be the
substance guy I mean that this is the
white house that has denounced leakers
instead of saying we should focus on the
substance when the substance is bad for
Trump now Sean Spicer says don't worry
so much about who got this where and
when let's focus on the substance which
appears to be completely distorted
anyway as usual whether the leakers or
the content matters depends on whether
it's good or bad for Trump I mean just
shocking shocking hypocrisy and double
standard discuss this with us on our
reddit discussion forum david pakman.com
slash re d di t today's program is made
possible in part by gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8000 new and classic
games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30 day free trial at gamefly
offer.com / tdps the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included no contracts and you can also
stream the games I think I mentioned
that you can also rent games through the
mobile app get a free 30 day trial
for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
gamefly offer.com /td PS